we're gonna go over to camille caustic i
know that name too hey tom
hi camille how you doing i'm doing good
i i know you probably weren't expecting
to hear me i'm corresponding with
entertainment tonight this week and when
i found out that i got to talk to you i
was like absolutely
let's do it like and tears over here a
little bit that it was really
um i really felt that when you were
speaking about that so thank you
um and i want to switch gears a little
bit because i feel like of all people in
rob's life
you and i spend probably some of the
most time with him so i know
at home rob and i know that you know
football
locker room rap so yeah please
tell me i saw a little bit of an
impersonation that you've done earlier
before and i got a kick out of it
because you did
pretty good i have to say because i like
to mimic wrap a lot
so can you tell me give me like an
insider edition of what it's like
i know you guys are super adamant about
your treatments as much as recovery
and training what's feel good got a
couple of tv 12 workouts then
locker room gearing up for super bowl
rob and you know what he's super excited
because
um you know he feels so good you know
he's played 20 games this year so it's
the most i think he's ever played in his
career so
you know he's a one of the most unique
people as you know
um just being around him he's so
positive i think everybody wishes
in their next life they can they come
back as as a as rob
just because he's got such a great
personality
about him just his way of being positive
and
he's a real high achiever he's very
competitive
and i see the competitive nature the
determination like if you're
you know when you're down and out you
want him with you and i think that
speaks to him as a teammate as a person
and um i love playing with him you know
he's i've known him for a long time
and i'm just so proud of all his
accomplishments he's an amazing guy
and uh you know i know for both of us we
we uh you know we we rely on each other
a lot for different things
and um you know i'll be looking for him
this sunday so that's the most important
thing
we're gonna go over to play 60 kid amy
brannon
hey tom i'm amaya how are you hi amaya
hi how are you good nice to talk to you
nice to talk to you too so i'm 10 years
old and
around the same age as your kids they've
chilled for you in almost every super
bowl you've been in
do you have any family traditions about
the big game and how will you celebrate
if you win
wow so how will i celebrate if i win
i'll be very
i'll be surrounded by my kids who are
your age so that's uh
the best part about winning is having
the people
uh that have helped you get there and
support you there with you to enjoy it
so
um some of the best memories i've had in
my life for being with my kids right
after the super bowl and
celebrating with them so i hope we have
that experience on sunday it's gonna be
a really tough game so
we're gonna have to go earn it but if we
get the job done it's
that's exactly what i'll be doing okay
thank you
thank you amaya you're welcome we're
gonna go over to greg almond
hey tom we hear a lot about the coaches
on this buck staff being early risers
how early in
they are under the office how early are
you getting into the facility this week
probably get in about um 6 15 or so
so pretty early i think some of them
beat me in
so i think everyone's in here to try to
get as much preparation as we can
there's a lot to study is a a uh a tough
team to prepare for
because they're very talented they have
a lot of great uh
things that they do on defense that
really challenge you so
um you know it's been a lot of
preparation
this whole time it's been a really
hardcore prep and now we ultimately have
to be confident what we're doing and
go out there and get the job done we're
going to go over to susie colbert
i know that name hi tom hi susie
so as we get closer to game time now
when we talk you mentioned
you know sunday is such a long day and
just not using up too much energy
i wonder obviously you've been down this
road what's the usual what's the sunday
routine and what have your
emotions typically been like as the day
progresses
you get closer to game time you walk in
the stadium
yeah it's just a uh you know it's a slow
build i think for this game because it's
a two weeks of prep
you know you feel like the physical
stuff's you know pretty much done at
this point
and at this point it's just going
through in your head different situation
scenarios all your different calls that
you'd have
um you know just trying to think about
how they're going to play us
and then again i think that's where the
mental prep you you really can't leave
any stone unturned at this point so
we've got friday saturday sunday three
three
just over three days left in the season
so
72 hours plus and uh
you know you got to use it all and use
it to to our to the maximum because
this is a game that's really going to
challenge us this team is a very tough
team to beat you know they haven't been
beaten
in a long time uh got a great offense
got a great defense really well coached
very good on special teams so um
just try to chill you know on sunday you
know get your get your body you know
mentally physically being a good place
to go out there and compete
and uh get ready for a great game so
it's a long game
it's a hard game you know it's a it's a
it's a long day
but you got to be ready when the ball is
kicked off and we're going to be
challenged they're going to challenge us
and we got to
go answer a challenge all right we're
going to go over to nora princioti with
the ringer
yeah hey tom um so both your offense and
kansas cities have converted
a decent number of third and longs this
season and i'm just curious sort of what
the mentality is
as an offense as a quarterback when you
manage to get one of those
and kind of stick it to a defense in
that situation when they might have
thought that they were about to get off
the field
it feels good to do that just because
you know you get
kind of behind the down distance on
first second down to leaves you in third
along and then
you're able to bail yourself out of that
situation so
it's a hard thing to do i wouldn't try
to make a uh
you know all day long you know trying to
stay in third and long and see if we
could
you know make a bunch of plays because
that's not uh
yes very low percentage football so
we're gonna have to play well on early
downs
keep our third down manageable eliminate
negative plays
eliminate negative runs sacks penalties
all those things are really important
it's got to be a really clean football
game because
you get stuck behind the down and
distance you know these guys do a great
job getting you off the field so
it's a um i think every play you know
we're gonna have to have maximum
concentration on
probably 70 70 plays left in the season
so all of them are going to have to be
our very best we're gonna go to jonathan
jones from cbs sports
hey tom your offenses over the nine
super bowls have combined to score
three points in the first quarter one of
those quirky little stats and i know
they're all
their own individual entity but did you
ever or have you since
tinkered at all with your prep as it
specifically pertains to the fourth
quarter and why or why not
uh i haven't thought about that much
um yeah you'd obviously love to get off
to a fast start
hard to explain why or why not that
hasn't happened i'm sure there are a lot
of individual things
um why that's happened or not so i don't
know i think ultimately for us this week
it's about
you know taking every play understanding
what we're trying to execute on a given
play and then go
go make it happen so you know the one
thing about this game you're playing the
other best team in the league
so there's not a lot of margin of error
if you do anything
that's uh unsound it's not going to work
so
execution has to be at your best and um
you know it should be that way that's
the way this game should be played it
should be the highest level of execution
and because it's the most time to
prepare concentration
focus um just gotta lay it on the line
and
and uh try to make the plays when we got
them
to you know when they're there to be
made we gotta make them we're gonna go
over to john crick from the toronto sun
four years ago this week i asked you how
the 39 year old tom brady would fare
against the 22 year old tom brady in the
combine agility and speed drills and you
said you'd crush it
yeah 43 year old tom brady fair against
not just a 22 year old but 39 year old
wow um
probably similar to when i was 39 um
i'd say pretty similar i think throwing
the ball
uh jody wise um
i'm gonna work on my speed this
offseason try to get my speed up a
little bit
i see all these guys running around i
got to make a few of those plays so
i got a you know i've already started
thinking about kind of
how i'm going to train so i'd say that's
the one thing that i want to
always keep working on and continue to
throw the ball well
um be in good position to throw the ball
accurately
continue to be a student of the game and
you know i think that's how you can
continue to uh you know make
improvements you can't ever think that
you're satisfied you got to continue to
build and grow and learn and evolve and
some things are you know going to
challenge you but you got to fight
through those things
and um you know from my standpoint
there's always room for improvement
our last one's going to come from jenna
lane hey tom could you just uh relay the
conversation that you had with jason
light about the number seven before
you decided to still play with number
12. you know
jason kind of gave you all the details
so you know i didn't want to come in
here and
you know i know numbers are you know for
some people mean a lot and chris was so
cool about it so
in the end i spoke to chris and he was
uh
you know he was amazing so i just love
my experience with chris and
uh you know he's a stud no matter what
number he's wearing 12
14. he's a baller so he could wear any
number and be great
and i was just very appreciative that he
uh he allowed me to use it
you